so a facebook
whistleblower
now believes that facebook is actually
not censoring enough
for her taste and that her their lack of
censorship is actually dangerous
to the
children that's all
[Music]
so a former facebook employee and
current facebook
whistleblower
has taken to 60 minutes and is as we
speak engaging and hearing with uh the
senate about these uh leaked documents
that she handed over to wall street
journal and then was immediately
subsequently interviewed about where
basically she makes the suggestion
that facebook is hiding the research
that would allow we're not only hiding
it hiding it but then not acting on
research that shows that algorithms like
what they have on instagram are harmful
to teenagers and that
i mean
and this is she's serious about this she
said facebook's algorithm is actually
helping to cause
ethnic cleansing
she went there she really did so uh if
you've been watching the hearing so far
i'm sure you've seen that blumenthal
that uh senator blumenthal and miss
haagen have been putting on their best
nancy grace what about the children it's
uh impression and so it's been a little
bit
theatrical to say the least
they've been repeating the same lines
over and over and over again and we can
look at uh this heavy article really
quick just to see some of the things
that she's been claiming now you can see
right here
says fauci as francis hagen
told 60 minutes the version of facebook
that exists today is tearing our society
apart and causing ethnic cleansing
it's weird and i'm explaining why in a
second but it says haagen told 60
minutes during her october 3rd 2021
interview i've seen a bunch of social
networks and it's substantially worse on
facebook than anything i've seen before
imagine you know what's going on inside
of facebook and you know no one on the
outside knows
yes because we had no idea
how bad facebook is when it comes to
literally anything to do with censorship
one way or the other anyway
also she also goes on to say uh i knew
what my future looked like if i
continued to stay inside of facebook
which is person after person after
person has tackled this inside of
facebook and ground themselves to the
ground
according to cbs news hogan secretly
copied tens of thousands of pages of
facebook internal research
she says evidence shows the company is
lying to the public about making
significant progress against hate
violence and misinformation and there it
goes
now we know what her goals are
and then she goes on to say
when we live in an information
environment that is full of angry
hateful polarizing content it erodes our
civic trust it erodes our faith in each
other it erodes our ability to want to
care for each other
it almost sounds like she's running for
president anyway uh the version of
facebook that exists today is tearing
our society apart and causing ethnic
cleansing around the world
she actually goes on to blame facebook
for the current uh crisis that's going
on in ethiopia
now why do i call that particular part
weird i'm not sure if you all recall but
um
do you remember the arab spring
do you know that the arab spring is
largely credited to facebook
there were some pictures of tunisian
violence that had been posted all over
facebook some of the protests in egypt
as well i mean one kid literally or one
family literally named their baby
facebook
that's when protests were celebrated now
it isn't a good look for the arab spring
because there's already already a lot of
speculation that the air spring was in
fact not authentic or organic but
actually manufactured by western powers
and western imperialist
and
it's kind of uh believable the latter i
mean
given that
you see now a 180 degree turn where
the violence when violence was posted on
facebook or the violence against the
people were posted on facebook uh in
2011 2010 2012
everybody saw that as a catalyst
remember they even tried to pull that
move with syria when they had all those
journalists who actually spoke really
good english for some reason and we
found out it's because they weren't
actual they weren't actually victims of
what they'd claimed in syria but instead
we're hired to do a job
we saw those journalists post about this
this is my you know my last video from
dumas or damascus or whatever
and then everybody was celebrating those
videos went viral millions and millions
of views
and then somebody asked a pretty wise
question
how the hell did they get an iphone and
then upload it
with hd quality
to facebook
people started asking questions
and even so but the protests and the
and what facebook could do in
circumstances like that were celebrated
and now
there's a claim on the other side that
facebook is actually fomenting the
violence
i want to be very clear about something
facebook
has been censoring the hell out of
everybody who is not towing the company
line
and like i just said we know hogging
right now is sitting in front of a
senate committee testing testifying
against facebook which is ironic right
considering
two weeks ago roughly around september
12th september 13th the wall street
journal once it gets crazy how the wall
street journal keeps getting all this
breaking news but the wall street
journal got some information
that demonstrated that facebook has a
white list
they have a white list despite
constantly denying that they play any
sort of favoritism with that with their
algorithms which also was hilarious
considering in their terms of services
and in their uh upgraded uh uh within
their upgrade agreement updated excuse
me agreement they actually are pretty
clear that they do play favors but they
lied about it when they were asked and
then
the white list comes out so if it's a
celebrity
or business etc that facebook likes
then
facebook green lights them and not only
greenlights them but promotes them
yeah
now nobody was actually called
for hearing
to testify
about why
certain celebrities certain blue checks
certain brands in general get such
special treatment but the moment that
this woman is yelling from because that
call based on everything that we've read
is why is there exclusivity there in
other words why is there a sort of
censorship being implemented uh that
gives preferential treatment to certain
celebrities that was what that call is
for this call is different
this call is
why isn't facebook censoring more
why is facebook allowing so many
opinions
to
to just to just float on the internet
but if the what if those opinions are
divisive
what about the children why is instagram
allowing children
to
see whatever instagram allows them to
see
now
it's not that those children have
parents who can regulate their
phone and the use of the apps on their
like they literally have the ability to
do that
but for some reason hogging actually
once
facebook to do the job of parents
or instagram to do the job of parents
i just want to be very clear about
something you can call me cynical
conspiracy theorists whatever
they haven't
at a single turn
made
a singular attempt to actually
hold facebook or any of the social media
tech giants accountable
they've had hearing after hearing after
hearing after hearing
do you know what it always ends up
leading to
no accountability on facebook no
retribution for the people who have been
harmed by facebook or facebook's
algorithms
but merely more censorship
that has always been the case
now i also find it
ironic that this also comes on the tale
of youtube making their announcement
that they will censor anything that they
consider
to be quote-unquote anti-vaxxer
that includes protesters and activists
now their
criteria for that is whether or not that
information is actually based
uh on the authority that they trust in
or the medical consensus so not even
whether or not the information is
factual
so if anything
facebook seems to be operating lockstep
in lockstep with with youtube and google
as usual
we're seeing more censorship come acro
come down across the board this is not
going to merely be limited
to to to
16 year olds in their feelings
okay this is this you know that that's
not where it stops and i like like this
is the same congress i just let a bunch
of 16 year olds starve and go homeless
during this pandemic okay
this is the same congress that told the
parents of these 16 year olds that they
don't need any more money while they
gave a bunch of money to the
military-industrial complex
a bunch of tax
uh uh
they gave they gave a bunch of tax
breaks to the wealthiest of this country
and even still
those 16 15 year old 17 year olds
who deserve a living wage as much as
anybody else in this country
are still being denied that by the
democratic house the democratic senate
and their democratic president
so i find it very very difficult to
believe
that any of this
is about the children
and
a woman comes out
by the way
founder she's the founder of hinge which
is a dating app which is super weird
she's been involved with google right
out of college
and facebook
and she was the head of misinformation
or not ah excuse me she was one of the
the managers in the misinformation
department at facebook specifically
her job has been to censor
and if she's coming out with this
information like
would it be outlandish to think that
she's being allowed to come out with
this information
would it would that be outlandish
because we all know facebook has been
trying to justify censorship for for
years now
and now it looks like they're not doing
it
themselves
of their own free will it looks like
they're being forced to and if they're
being forced to by the government then
they have to
so she gets a leak 60 minutes gives her
an interview she immediately gets a a a
a
she gets a hearing in front of the
senate and then what
then we get more censorship
i'd love to know what your thoughts are
about this like this video share this
video leave a comment below but always
remember more than anything else find
your balance
peace